[Music]
everyone says Islam is a religion of
peace all authorities in the western
world and yet all over the world we see
Muslims committing violence and
justifying it by reference to Islamic
texts how are we to understand this in
the first place we have to distinguish
between Islam and Muslims there's a
great deal of confusion on this point
people think that because they know a
Muslim who's a nice guy that Islam must
teach peace in fact the teachings of any
particular religion are one thing and
the way each individual puts those
teaching into practice is quite another
there's a spectrum of belief knowledge
and fervor among the adherence of all
religions some are very devout and
knowledgeable about their religion's
teachings others are devout but less
knowledgeable others are knowledgeable
but not devout and so on so one cannot
assume that just because a particular
Muslim is a good person that Islam does
not teach Warfare against and
subjugation of unbelievers unfortunately
does Islamic jihadis are very clear
about this always grounding their
actions in the Quran the holy book of
Islam and the example of Muhammad the
prophet of Islam Abdullah aam the
co-founder of al-Qaeda explained that
Muhammad he said was a master of the
mujahedin the Warriors of jihad and a
model for fortunate inexperienced people
the total number of military excursions
which he accompanied was 27 he himself
fought in nine of these and then aam
named some of the major battles in
Islamic history bad uhud Amari the
trench Kisa kibar the conquest of Mecca
hunain and ta he said Muhammad was on
all of these Expeditions and he said
this means that the messenger of Allah
used to go out on Military Expeditions
or send out an army at least every two
months and the Egyptian Islamic scholar
nasu Hamid Abu Z said if we follow the
rules of interpretation developed from
the classical science of quranic
interpretation it is not possible to
condemn terrorism in religious terms it
remains completely true to the classical
rules in its evolution of sanctity for
its own justification this is where the
secret he said of its theological
strength lies one finds the same thing
when one turns to the authoritative
sources in Sunni Islam the schools of
Sunni Juris Prudence or metad
the shafii Maliki Hani and hanbali these
are not brick and mortar schools but
schools of thought schools of law with
each prevailing in various regions of
the Islamic world and most Muslims
adhering to one or the other a manual of
Islamic law of the shafii school was
certified in 1991 by the clerics at
al-azhar University one of the leading
authorities in the Islamic world and
where Barack Obama spoke in 2009 they
certified this book as a reliable guide
to Sunni Orthodoxy and sunnis are 85 to
90% of Muslims worldwide this Manual of
Islamic law stipulates about Jihad that
the kff makes War upon Jews Christians
and zoroastrians until they become
Muslim or pay the non-muslim pole tax it
adds a comment by shik no Ali Salman a
Jordanian expert on Islamic Jurish
Prudence The caleff wages this war only
provided that he has first invited Jews
Christians and zoroastrians to enter
Islam in faith and practice and if they
will not then invited them to enter the
social order of Islam by paying the
non-muslim pole tax jizya which is
specified in the Quran and is a sign of
the subjugation of the non-believers
while remaining in their ancestral
religions without a caliphate only
defensive Jihad is allowed the goal of
defensive Jihad however is not peaceful
coexistence with non-muslims as equals
the same Manual of Islamic law specifies
that the Warfare against non-muslims
must continue until the final descent of
Jesus that's Jesus the Muslim Prophet
not Jesus the Savior after that nothing
but Islam will be accepted from them for
taking the pole tax is only effective
until Jesus's descent that is until
Jesus the Muslim Prophet Returns the
Christians may live subjugated under the
rule of Islamic law but when he returns
it's convert to Islam or die that
Warfare against unbelievers is being
pursued all over the world today